Border Patrol agents in South Texas are
searching for three missing migrants two
of them children after their raft
capsized while crossing the Rio Grande
yesterday they found the body of a ten
month old baby from the same group of
Central Americans US Customs and Border
Protection's say there were more than
103 thousand
unauthorized crossings at the southern
border in March the most in a dozen
years Malaya Villarreal is in Donna
Texas where tent cities are going up to
house migrants at the border may a good
morning well good morning family units
crossing the border legally and
illegally have increased by two hundred
and forty percent compared to last year
and that's prompted DHS to ask Congress
for more money to address the
humanitarian crisis here along the
border now we got a first-hand look how
some of that money could be used as we
toured the tent city here in Donna
that's supposed to give Border Patrol
some much-needed relief this is the
government's latest and largest attempt
at managing the record flow of migrants
along the southern border this facility
and another like it in El Paso will be
open for at least four months housing up
to 500 men women and children at a cost
of nearly 37 million dollars this is one
of four pods a hundred and twenty people
can fit in here during the day it is
empty people can walk around anywhere
they want but at night the mattresses
come down and people will be sleeping on
the floors at the height of family
separation last year outrage grew over
chain-link fences used to separate
minors and adults some called them cages
assistant Chief Carmen qualia says this
site will be different we are not going
to be putting in chain-link fencing in
this facility however we are going to be
putting in some partitioning
across the border in Reynosa Mexico we
found nearly 500 migrants living at the
way of life shelter these families are
waiting for their turn to legally seek
asylum and be processed at sites like
the one we toured this is the list this
is the list
pastor Hector Silva runs the shelter and
is the keeper of the list you can see we
got a group 15 yesterday it includes
Maria called their own and her
seven-year-old son we've been living
here for more than a month look at my
she says she Levin and swell abhi cuz of
the violence although it's unclear when
she'll get her chance to ask for asylum
she's willing to wait Border Patrol
agents say the plan is to actually hold
these migrants for less than 72 hours
but immigration attorneys are still
worried saying these families won't know
what their rights are when it comes to
asking for asylum and they're also
concerned that this facility is not
meant for children especially in the
light of knowing that three minors have
died in government custody over the last
year
vlad that's a startling statistic Maria
you've been covering the story from the
very beginning and we thank you very
much for it